In this video, we'll look at an
example in which we compute
the expectation and cumulative
density function of a mixed
random variable.
The problem is as follows.
Al arrives at some bus stand
or taxi stand at a given
time-- let's say time
t equals 0.
He finds a taxi waiting for him
with probability 2/3 in
which he takes it.
Otherwise, he takes the next
arriving taxi or bus.
The time that the next taxi
arrives between 0 and 10
minutes, and it's uniformly
distributed.
The next bus leaves exactly
in 5 minutes.
So the question is, if X is Al's
waiting time, what is the
CDF and expectation of X?
So one way to view this problem
that's convenient is
the tree structure.
So I've drawn it for you here
in which the events of
interest are B1, B2, and B3,
B1 being Al catches the
waiting taxi, B2 being Al
catches the next taxi, which
arrives between 0 and 5 minutes,
and B3 being Al
catches the bus at the
time t plus 5.
Notice that these three
events are disjoint.
So Al catching the waiting taxi
means he can't catch the
bus or the next arriving taxi.
And it also covers the entire
set of outcomes.
So, in fact, B1, B2, and
B3 are a partition.
So let's look at the relevant
probabilities.
Whether or not B1 happens
depends on whether or not the
taxi's waiting for Al.
So if the taxi is waiting for
him, which happens with 2/3
probability, B1 happens.
Otherwise, with 1/3 probability,
we see whether or
not a taxi is going to arrive
between 0 and 5 minutes.
If it arrives, which is going
to happen with what
probability?
Well, we know that the next
taxi is going to arrive
between 0 and 10 minutes
uniform.
It's a uniform distribution.
And so half the mass is going
to be between 0 and 5.
And the other half is going
to be between 5 and 10.
And so this is going
to be 1/2 and 1/2.
And let's look at what
X looks like.
If B1 happens, Al isn't waiting
at all, so x is going
to be equal to 0.
If B3 happens, which is the
other easy case, Al's going to
be waiting for 5 minutes
exactly.
And if B2 happens, well, it's
going to be some value
between 0 and 5.
We can actually draw the
density, so let's see if we
can do that here.
The original next taxi was
uniformly distributed
between 0 and 10.
But now, we're told two
pieces of information.
We're told that B2 happens,
which means that there's no
taxi waiting, and the
next taxi arrives
between 0 and 5 minutes.
Well, the fact that there was no
taxi waiting has no bearing
on that density.
But the fact that the next taxi
arrives between 0 and 5
does make a difference, because
the density then is
going to be definitely 0 in any
region outside 0 and 5.
Now, the question is, how
is it going to look
between 0 and 5?
Well, it's not going
to look crazy.
It's not going to look like
something different.
It's simply going to be a scale
version of the original
density between 0 and 5.
You can verify this by looking
at the actual formula for when
you condition events on
a random variable.
Here, it's going to be 1/5
in order for this to
integrate out to 1.
And now we can jump right into
figuring out the expectation.
Now, notice that X is actually
a mixed random variable?
What does that mean?
Well, X either takes on values
according to either a discrete
probability law or
a continuous one.
So if B1 happens, for example, X
is going to be exactly equal
to 0 with probability
1, which is a
discrete probability problem.
On the other hand, if B2
happens, then the value of X
depends on the density, which
is going to be continuous.
So X is going to
be a continuous
random variable here.
So how do you define an
expectation in this case?
Well, you can do it so that
it satisfies the total
expectation theorem, which means
that the expectation of
X is the probability of B1 times
the expectation given B1
plus the probability of B2 times
the expectation given B2
plus the probability
of B3 times the
expectation given B3.
So this will satisfy the total
expectation theorem.
So the probability of B1 is
going to be exactly 2/3.
It's simply the probability
of a taxi waiting for Al.
The expected value of X-- well,
when B1 happens, X is
going to be exactly
equal to 0.
So the expected value is
also going to be 0.
The probability of B2 happening
is the probability
of a taxi not being there times
the probability of a
taxi arriving between 0 and 5.
It's going to be
1/3 times 1/2.
And the expected value of X
given B2 is going to be the
expected value of
this density.
The expected value of this
density is the midpoint
between 0 and 5.
And so it's going to be 5/2.
And the probability of B3 is
going to be 1/3 times 1/2.
Finally, the expected
value of X given B3.
Well, when B3 happens,
X is going to be
exactly equal to 5.
So the expected value is
also going to be 5.
Now we're left with 5/12
plus 5/6, which
is going to be 15/12.
And we can actually fill that
in here so that we can clear
up the board to do
the other part.
Now we want to compute the CDF
of X. Well, what is the CDF?
Well, the CDF of X is going to
be equal to the probability
that the random variable
X is less than or equal
to some little x.
It's a constant [INAUDIBLE].
Before we jump right in, let's
try to understand what's the
form of the CDF.
And let's consider some
interesting cases.
You know that the random
variable X, the waiting time,
is going to be somewhere
between 0 and 5, right?
So let's consider what happens
if little x is going to be
less than 0.
That's basically saying, what's
the probability of the
random variable X being
less than some number
that's less than 0?
Waiting time can't be negative,
so the probablility
of this is going to be 0.
Now, what if X is between
equaling 0 and
strictly less than 5?
In that case, either X can fall
between 0 and 5 according
to this case, in the case
of B2, or X can be
exactly equal to 0.
It's not clear.
So let's do that later.
Let's fill that in later.
What about if x is greater
than or equal to 5?
Little x, right?
That's the probability that the
random variable X is less
than some number that's bigger
than or equal to 5.
The waiting time X, the random
variable, is definitely going
to be less than or equal to 5,
so the probability of this is
going to be 1.
So now this case.
How do we do it?
Well, let's try to use a similar
kind of approach that
we did for the expected value
and use the total probability
theorem in this case.
So let's try to review this.
First of all, let's assume that
this is true, that little
x is between 0 and
5, including 0.
And let's use the total
probability theorem, and use
the partitions B1, B2, and B3.
So what's the probability
of B1?
It's the probability that Al
catches waiting taxi, which
happens with probability 2/3.
What's the probability that the
random variable X, which
is less than or equal to little
x under this condition,
when B1 happens?
Well, if B1 happens, then random
variable X is going to
be exactly equal to 0, right?
So in that case, it's definitely
going to be less
than or equal to any value
of x, including 0.
So the probability will be 1.
What's the probability
that B2 happens now?
The probability that B2 happens
is 1/3 times 1/2, as
we did before.
And the probability that the
random variable X is less than
or equal to little x
when B2 happens.
Well, if B2 happens, this
is your density.
And this is our condition.
And so x is going to
be somewhere in
between these spots.
And we'd like to compute what's
the probably that
random variable X is less than
or equal to little x.
So we want this area.
And that area is going to have
height of 1/5 and width of x.
And so the area's going
to be 1/5 times x.
And finally, the probability
that B3 happens is going to be
1/3 times 1/2 again times the
probability that the random
variable X is less than or equal
to little x given B3.
Well, when B3 happens, X is
going to be exactly 5 as a
random variable.
But little x, you know-- we're
assuming in this condition--
is going to be between 0 and 5,
but strictly less than 5.
So there's no way that if the
random variable X is 5 and
this is strictly less than 5,
this is going to be true.
And so that probability
will be 0.
So we're now left with
2/3 plus 1/30.
And now we can fill this in.
2/3 plus 1/30 x.
And this is our CDF.
So now we've finished the
problem, computed the expected
value here and then the CDF
here, and this was a great
illustration of how you
would do so for a
mixed random variable.